in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some fitness
professionals with their big table index
design when we have the time to get an
extra workout in stay tuned to find out
from a performance perspective one of
the most important things to consider
while designing your big table schema is
your index design which is something
that our friends at urban Fitness Forge
makers of fitness tracker products ran
into headlong recently you FFC usage
pattern for their data dominantly
queried lat/long values to find specific
sensors within an area for analysis or
rather given how often they ran this
query it was way too slow for their
needs their initial schema design used a
row key comprised of lat/long values and
as it turned out this simple setup was
exactly the problem the reason for this
is two things working together firstly
BigTable doesn't have explicit support
for secondary indexes so if you want to
find a group of people with the same
first and last name then you can get a
very fast first name search but you have
to do a secondary search any less than
performant fashion secondly entries in a
tablet are sorted lexicographically by
their index meaning that entries with
similar keys will be closer to each
other in the tablet space now since the
dominant part of uff ski was the
latitude value other cities which shared
the same latitude value were listed
closely in the table meaning that their
secondary scan for a longitude value was
walking through loads more data and of
course was less performant as a result
this highlights an important aspect of
BigTable schema design the wrong key
design could spell disaster for your
performance for urban fitness forge that
meant creating an index such that
entries that are close to each other in
physical space were sort of close to
each other in table space to reduce scan
size so instead of using a lat/long
value which produced a raster style
order index like this one they were able
to use a space-filling curve which
organized indexes in physical space like
this the result is a modified index for
entries which use a space-filling curve
integrated with a timestamp value to
create a single integer based index for
urban fitness forge this meant queries
which looked for lat/long data had
reduced table scans resulting in a huge
perf improvement now obviously using a
space
curve is not the right solution for
every problem but it does offer a good
reminder to get the best performance out
of cloud BigTable it's essential to
think carefully about how you compose
your Roky if you're interested to know
more about this problem check out the
article linked in the description below
and don't forget to subscribe to our
YouTube channel for more great cloud
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts